welcome back to cbs this morning the
trump administration will
end its term amid what could be a
record-setting wave of federal
executions during a presidential
transition
they come after a 17-year hiatus in
executing federal inmates
eight inmates have been executed this
year and another four men and one woman
are set to die before inauguration day
our lead national correspondent david
begneau looks at the public push
to stop one execution scheduled for next
week he is at the federal prison
in terre haute indiana david good
morning
anthony good morning 40 year old brandon
bernard is set to die by lethal
injection
in one week here at the federal prison
in terre haute
he was convicted in the deaths of two
youth ministers back in 2000
he is pleading to be taken off death row
you might expect that
but you probably don't expect that one
of the prosecutors who helped put him on
death row
and five of the jurors who voted for
death
now say don't give it to him
gary mcclung is one of those jurors who
voted for death for brandon bernard back
in 2000
but in his heart he says he felt even
then that death was too harsh
why didn't you vote against the death
penalty then
i've just
i've always struggled i guess especially
at that time in my life
standing on my convictions and i regret
that now
the death penalty is far too harsh
for the his level of involvement in this
crime
kim kardashian west agrees the reality
tv star has successfully lobbied
president trump in the past on criminal
justice reform issues
she tweeted while brandon did
participate in this crime
his role was minor compared to that of
the other teens involved
two of whom are home from prison now i'm
part of this travis that is former
federal prosecutor angela moore
she successfully fought off an appeal by
brandon bernard
to try to have his conviction and
sentence overturned you went from
arguing he should be executed on behalf
of the government
to now making a case to say he should
not be executed what happened
the legal reasons aside from my own
personal beliefs is the evidence and
what we have found out
since mr bernard did not
shoot and kill the victims in this case
he was not the person who planned
this robbery gone wrong why didn't you
speak up then first of all it wouldn't
have mattered
the federal government when you're a
prosecutor at least in our district
you are not allowed to concede error
now the u.s attorney who runs the office
where angela moore used to work
told us she provided inaccurate
information and that if the law
and or facts establish reversible error
they will concede the error
for the last 20 years brandon bernard
has sat on death row
for being an accomplice in the murders
of todd and stacy bagley
he has counseled at-risk youth who are
on the outside
his lawyers set up a website called help
savebrandon.com
to make his case for clemency i can't
imagine how they feel
about losing their family and i wish
that
we can all go back and change it
make no mistakes about it brandon
bernard is not an innocent man
but the evidence shows he was not
involved in the planning of the
horrendous murders
of the bagleys they were youth ministers
who were carjacked abducted
and then shot fellow gang member
christopher v alva the shooter
he was executed back in september
brandon who was
18 at the time of the crime set the car
on fire with the bodies inside the trunk
prosecutors told the jury
that stacy bagley died because of the
fire that brandon bernard
started and they asked the jurors to
give him death for that reason
best i remember that was the reason the
for the um death penalty for brandon
bernard
that is what sweden yes yes but after
the trial an
independent medical examiner hired by
the defense
determined that one may reasonably
conclude that miss bagley was medically
dead
before the fire is this new
interpretation of the evidence
overwhelming enough to where you say
he should not have the death penalty oh
definitely
definitely the fact that brandon was
both
youthful and an accomplice i think those
are really potent reasons that support
mercy in this case
for 20 years attorney rob owen has
fought to get brandon bernard off of
death row
the jury was 11 whites and one
african-american member
the crime involved a group of black
teenagers committing a crime against two
white victims
those are dynamics which historically
have been associated with
uh pressure to return a death sentence
the jurors at bernard's sentencing
were told that he would likely be
violent in prison
but a former warden for the prison says
the opposite is true
the warden cited bernard's record of
zero infractions
and said he would function exceptionally
well in a less restrictive environment
without posing any risk he should not
be executed ever it's barbaric
it's horrific and he does not deserve it
the mother of todd bagley one of the
victims was quoted as saying
i believe when someone deliberately
takes the life of another
they should suffer the consequences for
their actions
there is only one person who can save
the life of brandon bernard and it is
the president of the united states
brandon is set to be executed in seven
days gail
boy david we just asked that question at
the table is the president of the united
states the only one that could save
uh brandon at this point you're saying
yes that's the only one
yeah thank you very much that's a very
complicated story as he as david pointed
out look he's not innocent no no but he
also pointed out he didn't shoot
he didn't fire the fatal shots and he
wasn't involved in the planning
and he was young i i i don't know you
listen to that and you see other people
who have done more
or less other countries don't have the
death penalty at all canada mexico so
there's also a bigger question here
about whether we want to do this yeah
should we execute people
yeah especially when it looks like you
could be executing someone that didn't
do
what he's accused of doing at this
particular time yes
all right it's up to president trump at
this particular point we will see